I never had control on a script in my
life more than in this movie I know that
you know Julian Fellowes is a big name
fantastic screenwriter but the reality
is that at the very beginning I I got a
script which she was only dialogue no
description at all no no blocking and
was very interesting I don't know if was
an experiment but certainly it was
incredibly involving you didn't need to
know where you were because if you were
in a state of mind where you would you
know you would witnesses to kiss fall in
love and I think that the the secret was
that for the first time I mean the
question is why making another Romeo and
Juliet you know do you go flashier than
bachelor Amanda you more do you go more
classical or bigger in scope than
Zeffirelli and that when I were in half
where I read the script at the end I was
in tears taught me that Julian wanted to
go deeper for the first time he want all
the characters even the most secondary
ones although there are no secondary
characters in movies to participate to
this tragedy to be you know to function
as an emotional conduit you know between
the story and the audience so I was
blown away by that and then what you
know I started the easiest process of
collaboration you know i would i would
put flesh over the bones and i would
tell you know Julian how I would see
scene where I would see it you know why
was important for me to push back the
story for 100 years so setting it you
read the rain and Sons are supposed as
the edge of the dark age where this
really movie takes place you know
shooting in real locations and you know
he we are setting in 1512 where all
these beautiful buildings when all these
beautiful buildings existed already I
suppose that's 100 years before where
the architecture was completely
different and I want to take advantage
of the color palette of all the
maestro's of the Renaissance of course
so what was incredible is that Julian
was always on call you know he came to
the set 2 3 times you know for a few
days because he's the Lord and also as
he has a job and the in the British
Parliament but he was always always you
know available to finish something you
know I would call him right you know
from the set and it was beautiful it was
absolutely beautiful and and and the
fact that I had such a great writer you
know allow me to focus on the visuals on
the you know we shot this movie in seven
weeks so it was very very quick and we
didn't have a big budget and so I was
glad that there was somebody else taking
care of the dialer this is the first
time we didn't come up with the idea of
the final duel with Paris it's in the
play but nobody has ever used it before
and I thought it was was great also you
know I wanted to make a movie that moved
that I had the sense of pacing a sense
of Ron and in some action sequences and
not gratuitous but in you know
absolutely you know inherent you know to
what the reasons the story develops Leon
of course I'm a big Stanley Kubrick fun
and and for me it was a moral choice
Leona's being Stanley Kubrick's personal
assistant for almost 30 years he
sacrificed his career as an actor to be
Stanley Kubrick second-in-command they
would do
you know to go to every theater you know
across the world to check the projector
supervising the Prince do doing the cast
the cast he helped to cast you know full
metal jacket he found the boy from the
shine and any Lloyd and I felt that for
all the reasons that when somebody dies
and people take over the estate etc that
the first thing they did was to get rid
of him and I I felt that this is a
talent and and you know like a pandora
boxx of very very important you know
treasures in terms of knowledge you know
a pack and passion and say you know
you're gonna be my my everything you're
gonna be the dialogue coach you're going
to watch over these kids because there
are too many of them so I'm gonna make
sure that the accent you don't want is
from Australia Haley is from Alex I want
to make sure that you know we have
consistency here and I want you to play
the Apothecary actually II he acted in a
movie in a stanley kubrick movie in in
eyes wide shut he will it was a red
clock the guy who's you know is the
master of the ceremony and he was pretty
scary just that you don't see his face
just the mask Leon is such an incredible
person such an incredible human being
and I really look forward to do many
other movies with him